Hey
You okay what have a kind of a hard time freezin I
Have an announcement I'm in love you sound insane. Whoa
There she is
Do it. She's too much for your little life Tay
Do we have any first-timers well, hello, dear hi, my name is Taylor
And I'm an alcoholic
Okay, Hey she thinks I'm a drunk. How can I be a drunk if I've never had a drink one Trini big deal?
What can happen?
Chicks like her don't fall for guys like you. You're a good guy looks memory. Good guys. They hope in love with bad boys. I
Can do that
Can happen to you, you know, visit being born and visit dying
18 I have a very old soul. Hey, MA
Sir we have a nice smoking nothing Oh
Everyone why is a guy like that in your world? I don't get it
There's a kind of guy who figures out exactly where you live and that ain't just Munoz here
Bobby let's take a rat. I'm gonna have to ask you to put that cigarette out
You know that
Told that we're all
Alcoholics did what today y'all just pretending to be an alcohol if you call me take teen front. I swear to God. Okay, Taytay
This is so crazy
Your eyes are so deep I'm drowning in them
That was too much wasn't it?
The more desperately you think you want something the more you're never ever gonna get it I
Think faith about us here faith that gives us wings or at least a soft place to land
You